all right Kim Bravo con you just kicked
it off with the og panel yes how'd it go
it was great it was actually a lot of
fun sitting up there did it make you
miss your Housewives days at all you
know what I'm very thankful for the
housewife days and then re-watching kind
of the footage I mean you know when I
think of housewives I think of Nene Kim
and Sheree and kind of all the memories
that we made and created and even the
argument so I mean I did have a good
time you have great girl time I love you
and Porsha's little reunion the other
day on Instagram so cute all those
ladies are here this weekend are you
gonna be running into them saying hi or
avoiding maybe Kenya Moore I love Porsha
Marlo I like most of them yeah all right
don't be tardy season eight is coming
can you believe eight seasons no I
cannot eight seasons and eight years
with Kroy yeah we saw you re watching
funny yeah yeah why the hell that didn't
register with me until just now but yeah
eight and eight right the show started
with your wedding Kim yeah hello good
morning sweetie
we saw you be watching the wedding
special though on Instagram how often do
you put that tape in and watch it do you
know what kya watches our wedding at
least twice a week so we actually see it
as well she loves to watch the wedding
but we try to watch it every year on our
anniversary just to kind of remind us
where we came from and and how much
we've grown and I mean thankfully I'm
very much in love with him so I don't
need a reminder of how much I loved him
them because I actually love him more
today why is that how would you keep it
fresh and spicy eight years in I don't
know you know what I got to be honest
with you I didn't think I could be with
anybody for like the rest of my life
because I kind of wanted mood changes my
taste changes I don't know I just think
where I was literally made for me you
know we just connect emotionally
sexually just the whole nine yards it
just kind of works and he's great and he
gets me and he lets me be me I think
that's a big thing he just lets me be me
and he's incredible dad's so oftentimes
throughout the day I look at him in like
how did I get so lucky I just hit the
jackpot for real
you really did I know all right season
eight what can we expect what can you
give me well this season is way
different than any other seasons before
so stay tuned it's a lot I test my
patience this year that different
sounded like a low different not a
surprise
lots of lows lots of highs and no real
in-betweens last question here we saw I
mean
ariana is just growing up she put on the
Playboy after for Halloween and people
had things to say like they always do
about 18 now so it was like do it you
know I think she's been dying to be 18
so that she could do something like that
or do her lips or do whatever she want
you know she's been dying to be 18
she's been on camera since she was four
years old she started at 4:00 with
Housewives of Atlanta and I know a lot
of people I was shocked by that I don't
know I just she actually was running
errands for me all day and she had a
Halloween party and she's like mom I
need one of your costumes like what am I
gonna do and I was like well I don't
know what you can like what do you want
I don't really dress up sweetie all I
have is that playboy costume she's like
I'll try it and it worked so it wasn't
like she had planned for it but it
worked out and she looked great in it so
18 and she wants to do the lips join mom
and sister I mean she's you know blessed
in that arena but I mean I you know
after watching Brielle and I she's
probably a little bit more motivated but
I'm like you're 18 until you're 18
there's you know you can't do anything
and that's kind of been the rule in my
house so she turned 18 and month ago so
we're doing okay
[Music]